et
g
le saluer au nom du gouvernement en ont
bloqué toute offense tous les jeunes et
je le fais un cadeau le plus beau cadeau
tu épuisé mais l'équipe de france
c'est beau
elle coule demande
forcément
non
à minuit
m
bassila koné
chez les gt c'est robert pires je
prépare quand on peut
je m'éclate l'enfant c'est quand même
pas mal
je vais donner davantage mais ça nage
je pense que ça des répercussions
nationale d'abord
du changement du climat de l'ambiance de
la confiance en soi chaque responsable
qu'ils soient politiques qu'ils soient
de quelques situations de la vie
publique à à réfléchir sur la façon dont
il doit continuer de porter cette
dynamique et les conséquences en sont
épatantes parce qu'on a montré qu'en
fait la france est une nation unie sans
distinction entre les uns les autres
hu